okay Garak back stories go what are you
talking about this is the elite of the
elite gear we gotta have backstories I'm
Garrett lobster the marketing no no no
Goering bro art gallery openings are the
boss level of society no extra lives low
on ammo out of potions potions sorry I
know I've been gaming a lot they call it
champagne okay here's my character my
name is Ricardo Magnuson oh geez I was
born in Helsinki retired at 25 after
selling my semiconductor startup these
days I bounce back and forth between my
flat in London and my beach villa on the
sands of nice is in no way believe my
deepest secret once a year I steal solo
to my private island in the BVI and lay
a single rose on the simple grave of my
former manservant and confidant me in
service Babel I'm gonna go try to enjoy
some of these
Oh wait bro I've got your backstory okay
what if you're like Gustavo son who's
taken over as my new manservant but he
has like a lot of growing up to do fine
I'm Gustavo son whatever don't speak
back boy more potion oh my god everyone
is staring this is totally gonna work he
isn't that isn't that that girl you were
dating oh my god oh my god bro tell me
she did not see me why was the big deal
but you get stopped going out anyway
there was no reason really you were like
super into no I thought that's I
remember because one day in the living
room you were doing situps in every rep
you're like Stephanie Stephanie stiff
okay okay I may have sent her a pic what
do you mean a pickup pic gare a photo a
dick pic bro I I text her a picture of
my man parts why would you send anyone a
dick I was getting the vibe from one of
our texting combos
Stephanie's emoji game is super fiery
and then and then radio silence we like
never spoke again so I guess that makes
sense so it doesn't make sense Garrett
because this was like the best dick pic
of all time I don't want to hear any
quality no shop at the pic you edited
the pan touched up color corrected clone
stay so worried about that visco film
pack a green screen myself on a yacht in
the riviera that seems way overboard
exactly that was the coolest part I was
like hanging dong over the railing but
still somehow perfectly silhouetted
against the seagulls this photo makes no
sense why are there seagull a lover of
art like Stephanie have no response to
that she's walking over oh god no okay
wait do I have time to throw the plan to
do an ahjussi hi Quinn seventy hey I was
just gonna come say hi you know I all
right to see you anyways how about this
new artist right really interesting
media he's working with what do you
think of his palette some people have
called as color choices too aggressive
really until it's the best
Quinn what do you think of this diptych
I'm sorry what why'd you say diptych to
painting son closely together as a pair
this is a great example of that Quinn I
guess I'm just surprised I thought you
didn't like diptych so what that's crazy
I love a good diptych honestly the
bigger the better just massive I mean
that's weird because it sounds like the
opposite of how you reacted to my dip
this artist often work in mixed-media
Stephanie now this series of work as a
departure for him and I'm really excited
because okay we just like cut it out and
stop pretending like we're not going to
talk about it
talk about what Quinn real talk I know
that you feel a sexual tension right now
I'm not sure I get what you're talking
about do you mean between you and Darren
between you and me because of the
picture hmm I picture the one I texted
you Quinn I think you've had too many
posts from my yachts oh of course that
picture yeah I knew that would come up
sooner or later or never in Quinn's case
boom
Savage burns a little blow Stephanie
that shot connected it's tough when
you're aiming for such a small target if
you want the clone stamp a clone stamp
stir for imperfections you know what
let's just go our separate ways and you
can live with knowing that you have no
appreciation for the greatest dick pic
of all time no Quinn I I actually loved
it really yeah absolutely that's why I
made nude posed on yacht flaccid the
focal point of the whole show the nude
what why now
oh you didn't see it no no no okay
Stephanie we got we got to take it down
we got to take it down now
oh now the seagulls make sense what's
that you want the photo on t-shirt no
I'm not saying I'm saying take it down
great idea I thought the same thing
looking great Stu fun always grab your
face out of a dick pic that was a
private photo Stephanie I was not meant
for public eyes
sup guys subscribe to the GQ channel and
stay tuned for my next Photoshop
tutorial and dick pics we'll be going
over all my presets and filters and I'm
going to show you guys how to use chroma
key